rohit Anifah the kaya boy civic center
is a 13.8 million dollar community
facility housing the kaiapoi library
service center art space and museum the
1892 square meter civic center in the
heart of kaiapoi was designed by leading
architects Warren and Marnie and built
by Hawkins construction the entrance
from the William Street Civic Square
leads into an open bright welcoming
interior the service center reception
and interview rooms are adjacent to the
entrance over 30,000 items are housed in
the library's collection with the
fiction section on the ground floor an
informal Reading area opens onto Raven
key and the Civic Square library books
are self issue and there are six public
internet access computers available the
children's section of the library is an
exciting space for young learners
partitioned from the remainder of the
library but both visible and accessible
by parents and adults the library
extends to two floors on the upper level
nonfiction titles are arranged in two
areas one of which houses newspapers and
periodicals and provides conveniently
large viewing tables both areas are open
to the ground floor connecting library
users on the upper level our meeting
rooms available for community groups use
and accessed through the library during
opening hours or by the back stairs or
lift after hours toilets and kitchen
facilities are also on the upper level
on the ground floor adjacent to the car
park entrance is the art space which
hosts regular exhibitions and the
kaiapoi museum exhibit of kaya poi rua
tallava an exciting new community
facility distant to become a popular
focal point for kaiapoi
you